Okay. Hey everyone, it's Michael Btos
from Orderflows and this is the
Orderflows market analysis for Friday,
June 23rd, 2017. And the week started
off gang busters. S&Ps, Dow, all new
highs rallying up. Very strong rally.
Tuesday gave it all back. Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday market was pretty much
unchanged and Dow I think and S&Ps
settled the week actually down for a
small loss, small loss on the week.
NASDAQ though was a big a big winner
this week. big gains in biotech. Uh
ended up the week about just shy of 2%
up. Oil though, oil had uh even though
oil was was up today. It was above 43
bucks. It was very uh very bad week for
crude oil. Well, bad for bad for the
market in terms of being down. It was
down about uh 3.7% for the week. I mean,
I I I hate to use the term it's bad when
price of oil is down, but um I like
lower oil prices. So anyway, um that
said, let's uh jump into the market
analysis. Before I do, I'll go through
the disclaimer. This presentation is
forformational and educational purposes
only and is should not be considered a
solicitation of buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contain stanial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing ones. Financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading. Those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading.
Past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. The tools
I want to talk about in this uh
presentation or tools I use rather in
this presentation that I talk
about are the orderflows trader volume
footprint chart which is available at
orderflows.com and the delta scalper
indicator. So let's just jump right into
it. S&P is you know um we'll take a look
at the daily chart. You know, I like to
get a reference in the morning of where
the market is based on the daily chart.
So again, you know, Monday, big up day.
Tuesday, no follow through, right? Lower
high even. You know, really what you
want to see when you have a big update
like this closing up towards your high,
you want to see the follow through when
the market reopens and going into the
evening session, you don't get it. And
that just tells me the market is weak.
Um, you know, the rest of the day it
sold off, which again, you know, this
was the sign early that we couldn't
continue in the night session. Um I
didn't expect this market to just sort
of go sideways like this. Um you know it
it Wednesday was down a little bit.
Thursday, Friday pretty much unchanged
um both
days. But again, you
know, I was looking for a little bit of
a selloff honestly. But you know, I just
wasn't giving it. You know, this market
is a lot of indecision right now in this
market. Every time you you rally up to a
high, you sort of get these dogey
candles. Here we rally up um late May
Dogee
candles. Although this is, you know, one
of these is Memorial Day. But then, you
know, you hear new highs and you just go
sideways, new highs and then you just go
sideways. So, I mean, who knows? It
could just be a launching pad for moves
moves higher. Um from here, again, I'm
not one of these doom and gloom skeptics
and going to say, "Oh, the market's
topping up here." I'm not going to say
that every day. Then when the market
does sell off, they'll be, "Oh, I told
you so." You know, I know people like
that. They they'll sit there and sky is
falling. Sky is falling for 5 years.
Then when it does fall, I told you so.
Well, yeah, in the meantime, the market
was up, you know, 20%. You, you know,
there's people, you know, that's how
they think. They're like, well, people
call the told you so is they like to
jump out and say, I I told you so. Um,
with the
markets, when I say people, I'm talking
about certain analysts at at companies.
Um so anyway S&Ps 10 range chart coming
into the morning very tight range 36 and
3/4 high 31 low just before seven you
know you get the uh price rejector given
a buy here delta scalper in the next bar
again it's you where you going to go
right next bar is going to be up you're
going to run right into your your high
but you know again it's it's coming in
right around 8:00 you know I do know the
cash is going to open up and at 8:30 so
it's going to be relatively soon and you
know things can change really quick when
the cash opens and you can see it does
it selling just comes right in um almost
immediately you got a bunch of
imbalances in the bar which by itself is
is uh bearish now you know when you're
dealing with imbalances you know most of
the time we like to see stacked
imbalances one on top of each other here
they're spread out you got one two then
a group of two then one down here so
it's a 10 range chart you got five
imbalances it's almost half the
bar that's imbalanced and you So that to
me that's a very bearish sign. Even
though they're not stacked visually it's
nice to see a stacked imbalance cuz
it'll draw out a nice zone. But you know
being a trader you got to analyze what's
happening in the market. Even though
it's not stacked perfectly it's a bunch
of imbalances in the bar and it's
telling you hey you know strong selling
is coming in. You got a big strong
negative delta as well and the market
sells off right. So, even if you were
long off this bar here with the Delta
Scalper, watching how the market's
unfolding over the next bar is one going
to tell you you should get out of this
trade and two, it should be telling you
you should think about getting short.
Okay, so we do sell off, make new lows,
hit this new low just before 10:00.
Delta Scalper again on the low of the
day, which is nice. You've got a
divergence. You got a nice strong
positive delta 4,600. You know, this is
your strongest delta of the morning,
either positive or negative in in the
absolute sense. And you got some nice
big chunky imbalances in there, a buying
imbalance 3,200. So, I know it's
changing. I know it's changing from a
supply driven market with a lot of
selling going in, a lot of supply being
distributed to now in sort of I'll say
accumulation phase, but um a demand
driven market, you know, where people
are are wanting to be lifting the offer
and do it aggressively. Next bar you got
a ratio. So, you know, you have Delta
Sculper here, you have a divergence, no
ratio, it's 10. Next bar, you got the
ratio. And what do I say? Every freaking
day it says I say look for
ratios with divergences and if you don't
have the ratio in the bar with the
divergence look to the next bar and here
you got it. You rally all the way up to
new
highs. Yeah, you go from this low delta
scalper said you know even if you're not
convinced I'm buying on this delta
scalper should be looking to get long
based off this next bar with the
divergence and the ratio and you rally
up into new highs. You get a couple
divergences. no ratios in here. So, not
really any major reason to be getting
short up in there. Um, then later in the
day, you got this. You sell off from
your high back down to your opening
price. It's almost um I don't want to
say half back, but you know,
that's to me that that looks like almost
a fib fib.
Uh I'm just
curious what sort of retracement you're
looking at
here. Whoops. Hang on.
Chart's all screwed up
here. Oops. Hang on.
Whoops. Give me a sec here. I'll get the
retracement level here. So, from your
low, which is this level up to your high
of the
day. Might have to scrunch this chart up
a little
bit. Yeah. Well, it's it's not 61. 61.8
is actually where this point of control
is. Um, so you get down to about 76,
then you were bounced back up and you
start coming back down. I know again,
you know, fib guys, oh yeah, you know,
you sold off there and boom, we rally
back up. Okay, fair enough. Um, but
anyway, yeah, so you you you bounce off
the opening price. To me, it's
important. You know, the opening price
is always a target when you're coming
off from your high. Where can you go to?
You go to your opening price, or if
you're rallying off your low, look to
rally up to your opening price. You
know, when the market's going sideways,
you tend to rotate around your opening
price. And next bar, delta scalper and a
ratio, but it's coming into the cash
close. You know, it's 258 here. Cash
close. Boom. Big selling comes in. Um,
you know, 12,000 on the delta, which is
quite big as well. You know, you had
10,000 here. So, these bars, you know,
again, this to me, this is just cash
close activity. It's Friday afternoon.
Um, cash close. You're going to see a
lot of volume going through. And you do
you see close to 300,000 lots over these
two
bars. So that was uh S&Ps. Bonds bonds
were kind of quiet actually.
Um where are we here?
[Music]
Bonds. Okay. So bonds, you know, again,
yeah, you had a ratio with divergence
and a point of control right on the low.
I literally show you guys these charts
every single day in in the same markets.
I'm showing you the same markets. So,
it's not like I'm showing you one day in
the bond market. Oh, here you have it.
Then I don't show you bond market again
for 2 weeks. You know, I show you some
other obsolute market. No, I've shown
you the same markets. The same things
happen daily. Um point control on the
bottom ratio and divergence. Market
rallies up, you know, six, seven ticks
there. Comes down ratio, sorry,
divergence. No ratio ratio in the next
bar. Yeah. Runs up here to a bear
bullish, sorry, a bearish ratio. You got
point of control up near the top. You
know, at this point, it's all about
managing your trade. And, you know, to
me, this this trade didn't really work
out. I'm not going to say, yeah, you
would have bought it in here in this bar
and held it down to here and rally back
up here and got out. No, to me, this
this bar, you know, sort of spoils it
and, you know, you're just trying to cut
your loss here. You know, maybe you lose
a tick or two there. Eventually, it does
rally up into new highs, but again, you
know, not much there in the bonds, but
there was a couple ratios with
divergences there. Um, fives
Where's my fiveyear chart? There it is
again. You know, very very tight range
here in the five years. Um, not really
much of anything this morning. You know,
you do have a divergence up here at the
high, but a very tight range. Very tight
range. It's uh 11809 to 11812 and a
quarter. So, very very compact range
this morning. So again, know it's hard
to trade hard to get any decent trading
options when you you're just rotating
around your opening price there like
that, you know, and like I said, you
know, on directionless days, that's what
the market does is it rotates around
your opening price. Oftent times it
it's, you know, it's I don't want to say
it's value, but that's what you do,
right? I mean, when there's no
direction, where you going to hang
around? You hang around unchanged. and
you know where the opening auction
occurred. Um take a look at some of the
currencies now. The
uh finger hurts. Um okay. So yen again
not much you know not much activity. Not
much I'll say not much activity but not
a whole lot of stuff going on in the
market. So here you got you know delta
sculper and a red bar. I'm not
interested here. You got it on a green
bar. I'm interested. It does rally up.
Get some trap traders up here. Market
starts to come off. Um you know, boom,
boom, boom. You hit this swing low,
bounce up a little
bit, get up here towards the high, get
within one tick of the high. Nothing up
in here telling me to get short. Stacked
in balance market just goes sideways.
Another stacked and balance market goes
sideways. Pops up a little bit and just
again this market also is just hanging
around your opening price. you know, I
didn't even, you know, on your volume
profile, this is how it
looks and you just sort of end out the
day. So, again, it was sort of
a a neutral day as far as the uh the yen
was
concerned. Okay. So, the last market
I'll talk about here is uh soybeans. And
you know, soybeans closed and they
reopened at 8:30. you know, right before
that you had a ratio with the
divergence, but again, I'm not going to
say take a trade right before the the
market closes and reopens. So, you know,
you got the delta sculper right on the
reopen. Again, you know, I'm not a big
fan of taking signals right on the close
or the open of the market. So, anyway,
that said, market sold off right after
the
reopen. You got down here, you got a
ratio of divergence. It doesn't work
out. The next bar comes right back down.
Okay, stops you out. Fair enough. Next
bar down here um potential long entry is
you got a green bar. I love this the way
this delta went from minus 258 to
positive 10 and closing at -12. Next bar
you got the delta sculper giving you a
nice buy signal and you know the market
rallies up from you know 902 and 1/2 all
the way up to 6 1/2 and then works its
way back down comes back up to that uh 6
and 1/2 level which is the opening
price. Um, yeah, you got a single print
when you trade up
there. Or is it here? The two lots. You
know, the first time you trade, you get
up here, you know, you got eight lots.
Second time, a little bit less. Fair
enough. I'm not yet convinced that
that's a big sell signal either. Um,
though. But again, you test the low
again. 45 lots trade. You have negative
delta. Green bar though. Um, next bar,
you got the ratio. No divergence though
in this bar at the low cuz you got the
negative delta. You come down, you you
get up the swing high, sell off again,
you got a new low, you got a divergence,
but you don't have a ratio. Next bar,
you got the ratio. And again, you know,
again, this is going into the close,
though, right? It's it's uh Friday
afternoon 104, markets closing in about
10 minutes. You know, heaven forbid you
have uh your system crashes and in those
that 10-minute window. But, you know, if
you got a good system and faith in it, a
trading system, meaning your
connectivity is fine. Um I I've had one
or two issues over the years where I've
lost connectivity and I had to restart
everything. So you know again I'm not
usually looking to take trades um right
on the close but going into the close.
But you know again you know if if you
have a good system or you're trading in
a place that uh you know it's solid.
Yeah, you could definitely take this
trade. You know it's 106. You're going
to have about 10 minutes to get whatever
you can out of the trade. You know from
9:02 back up to the 9006 area. Then you
get up here you got some trap traders.
But again, you know, I don't want to
start micromanaging all these little
moves as you're coming in 5 minutes
before the close, but this one was
definitely doable. Um whether you want
to be taking this or even this delta
scalper 2 minutes before the close is
another story. So, you know, there were
some decent trades there in the uh in
the beans as well. So, you know, even
though today was kind of uneventful for
the S&Ps, it did uh there were
opportunities in the S&Ps were
opportunities in the uh in some of these
other markets. So, thanks for watching
this. Uh to learn more about trading
with Orderflow, visit my website,
orderflows.com, and be sure to subscribe
to my channel. Thanks everyone. Bye-bye.